Do you have something for sleep if a hard time is going to sleep and stay to sleep?
This is a loaded question because there are so many possible causes of inability to fall
asleep and stay asleep.
Really have a hard time falling asleep is a totally different problem than someone who wakes
up and then can't go to sleep.
So if you are somebody who is waking up and then you're and can't fall asleep, let's just
walk through some possibilities here because there's a lot of different possibilities
when we talk about sleep issues.
So number one is I can't fall asleep.
I go to bed.
Well that's what's called insomnia.
But it's time to go to bed, it's really my time to go to bed.
I gotta get up at 6 o'clock and it's 10.30 and go to bed and you lay at bed for an hour
or so before you can fall asleep.
That's insomnia.
So insomnia can be caused from multiple things there.
You've spoken about it in past Zoom calls, stop looking at screen time several hours before
bed because watching a screen like a computer screen or your phone screen or a television
screen, the screens are functioning at a very high hertz, 60, 50 to 60 hertz is what they're
functioning at.
That is a training your brain at 50 to 60 hertz.
Your brain waves are only supposed to be functioning at the highest hertz of about 28 hertz which
is a high beta wave.
So your training your brain at a super high beta wave, of course your brain can't go that
high but you're in training your brain to be a high beta wave.
Nobody can fall asleep in a high beta wave.
You have to get down to a theta wave to get to sleep somewhere between 5 and 15 hertz
to be able to start to fall asleep.
So it's difficult to be sluky at your phone and it's time to go to bed so you put your
phone by your side of your bed and you try to go to sleep.
That itself doesn't allow your brain to get to a theta wave to get to sleep.
That itself can be a problem.
So number one, you can't fall asleep, stop using screens several hours before you go to
bed.
Well, I do that already and I still can't fall asleep.
The thing that could be taking place is you have a little teeny gland in your brain called
your PDL gland that's supposed to be secreting melatonin at the time before you're supposed
to go to sleep.
So you can use some melatonin, it's typically recommended that you use about 3 milligrams
of melatonin about a half hour before bed to help fall asleep.
We have melatonin in our store.
We also have a product called Insomnetol in our store that has some melatonin, has some
Valerian root and some other herbs that can be very calming to help you fall asleep.
So number one, screen time, number two, low melatonin levels.
Melatonin levels are also controlled and go along with an adverse relationship with cortisol.
Cortisol is a stress hormone.
So if I am under a lot of stress, this is why, if you have ever been under a lot of stress,
it's difficult for you to fall asleep.
So it is because if you have a lot of stress, you have a lot of cortisol secreted, you have
a lot of cortisol flying through your bloodstream, you won't make melatonin or you won't release
melatonin from the PDL gland and it's going to be difficult to fall asleep.
But the only stress levels, that's why sometimes people do better exercising at night before
bed because it can help burn off some of that cortisol and that helps them their body release
melatonin to help them fall asleep.
So exercising before bed can be beneficial in that case.
There's other reasons why you can't fall asleep and we could talk for a long time on just
the sleep patterns.
Now, waking up in the middle of the night and not being able to fall back asleep has to do
with other issues that could be very complex too, but usually are not related to melatonin.
They can be related to a adrenal burn out because at night, so at night, you're in a fasting
state.
So you have it eaten since night of clock or something like that and now you're fasting.
There's one part of your body that needs glucose all night long.
Your muscles don't need a lot of glucose because you're not exercising.
The rest of your body doesn't need a lot of glucose so you're not doing a whole lot of activity.
Things are in a stall mode while you're sleeping, but your brain is always active.
In order for your brain to continue to be active, it needs glucose.
Your adrenals release cortisol at night to stimulate glucose breakdown of glycogen
stores in the liver to keep a steady glucose level to keep your brain alive.
So what a person says, I wake up about water, I fall asleep just fine, I wake up about
water to a clock and I can't fall back asleep again.
That's usually because their adrenals are deficient.
People may be because of past stress, maybe current stress, but their adrenals are deficient.
So they need some adaptogens or some adrenal support and if you can support the adrenals
to get healthy adrenals again, then all that whole system can start working again.
There could be some other things with some mineral deficiency that can cause a person to
not be able to fall asleep or not be able to get back asleep at night either.
As this little diagram talks about leg cramps, that would be the mineral deficiency issues.
Acid reflux, well that's good back to gut health.
And other issues like pain, so pain can be an issue that keeps a person up and doesn't allow
them to get back asleep.
I would suggest if you really have issues with insomnia and sleep patterns that you do call
and make an appointment to talk about them if you can't deal with it to kid figure it out
with some of the brief things I spoke about here.
Another thing to try is the insomnia programs on your life.
We've had people say they've tried them but it didn't help at all.
We've had other people say they tried them and it was a miracle thing for them.
So melatonin, think about that.
Side note on that, high dose melatonin has been shown in several studies that it's been
helpful for some cancer patients to help with their cancer.
So melatonin is not contraindicated for cancer patients.
It can be helpful for cancer patients.
So I would not discourage you from trying melatonin.
You know, I don't want to do that that I'm going to be dependent upon it.
It can be good for your cancer.
So I would say definitely try melatonin.
The insomnia is all chronic we have.
We've had a lot of people with very good success with that.
There's a whole bunch of other reasons why a person isn't fully asleep.
Well, part of it has to do with glutamate levels.
Hopefully with most of our cancer patients we have been working on reducing glutamate levels.
Because high glutamate will keep you awake.
That's that or transmitter.
That's an excitatory or transmitter for your brain.
So hopefully you're already working on glutamate levels.
So that's not the piece that's keeping you awake.
Because remember glutamate converts to glutamate and feeds cancer.
So we don't put high levels there for other reasons.
But if you have more trouble that did the answer here.
Maybe we could get into it at a at a whole call itself.
But I know I address some of these in other zoom calls as well.
Next question.
I've been reading a lot about curcubid and what it does for cancer.
Should I be taking curcubid?
So number one, remember we put your protocol together because that's what it tested for you.
I'm not opposed to people adding supplements to the protocol that I created.
Better fact, I'm not God and you have to do what God is leading you to do.
So I have some patients that I strongly recommend that they don't be taking X, Y and Z supplements.
And yet they still take them because they feel led to do so.
Well, I'm all in support of what you have to do.
So I'm not, I don't know everything.
And you have to do what God's leading you to do.
That being said, curcubid is one of those that everybody could take.
So curcubid is the active form of the nutraceutical that's found in turmeric.
Turmeric is an Indian spice.
You could take turmeric directly as a spice, but it doesn't absorb very well.
You take it with black pepper and a fat helps that.
The fat actually helps the absorption.
The black pepper helps the half life in your body.
We use a curcubid that is in a form that is readily absorbed.
It has a lower half life.
It's a C3 reduct tetrahydro curcubid or curcubidoid.
But that's the product that we have.
So I have multiple videos just on curcubid.
And you can find those on the resources page of our website.
So I am a huge fan of curcubid.
Curcubid is very good for a lot of different things.
Curcubid is good to help decrease tumor metastasis,
decrease tumor cell growth, it's known to stimulate apoptosis.
And most people use curcubid for just inflammation to decrease inflammation.
Very, very helpful.
So I have very pro curcubid.
We have our own C3 curcubid.
It's called curcuclear.
And each capsule is equivalent to about one gram curcubid.
So typically, when you're dealing with cancer, one to three grams is spied.
Some cancers like multiple myeloma have been shown to need more and do real well with more.
We have multiple, we have many multiple myeloma patients.
Seven of them have tested out fantastic on it and we have them up to eight grams of curcubid.
So that's a lot, but it's been shown to be very helpful.
Can you take too much curcubid?
You could take too much anything.
So if you have a tested for it, meeting with me, I'd say one to three grams should be your maximum dose.
Next question, one of the best things to do after removing a cancer is two or so.
What's the best thing to do after surgery really is the question?
If I have surgery and I have a cancer diagnosis, what should I do?
Well, I made a video.
Maybe it isn't published yet. It's a blog post.
I don't think I scheduled to publish it.
It's, it's not going to be published for a week.
So lots of times I'll write blog posts that'll put them out in time so that my blogs come out in a series.
But it's on dealing with surgery.
There's a new study that just came out that actually confirms something that I've said.
There are other times that we don't want to have elective surgeries if we can help it when we have a cancer diagnosis.
That's why I've been told.
I've told you guys multiple times that I'm not a big fan of, okay, I had, but I had best tech to be because I had breast cancer.
But now I'm going to have surgery to have breast implants.
I understand I'm not a woman and I don't know what it's like to have to not have breast and and all the emotions that go along with that.
But when we do a, when we perform a surgery of any kind, even to remove a cancer's tumor,
the way your body has to heal itself is to upregulate IGF one.
However, IGF one is your growth hormone initiator.
So IGF one levels are how you heal.
So in order, if I even cut myself, how do I heal that cut?
IGF one levels are up regulated, being increased.
And that stimulates an increase in that and tore pathway.
That's right.
Ever we've spoken about that and nausea.
So when we upregulate the mTOR pathway, it increases my ability to heal by that, that wood is scarred over.
And I heal nicely and go, wow, look at I healed so well, that's wonderful.
But you did so by upregulated mTOR and IGF one pathways.
When you upregulate mTOR and IGF one pathways, with a cancer diagnosis, it is, I hate to say it,
but it is like throwing gasoline out of fire.
So we want to do things to downregulate the mTOR and IGF one after surgery.
So the best way to downregulate mTOR and IGF one is through fasting.
But I'll say it again, cancer patients cannot fast more than 24 hours at a time, if we're talking about a true water fast.
That's why we talked about doing intermittent fasting or what's called time restricted eating.
So you actually are fasting every day, but it's only a fast of maybe 16 to 20 hours a day.
If your time restricted eating is limited to 4 to 8 hour window.
So if you're eating within a 4 hour window, which would be a pretty tight time restricted eating window, that means you're fasting 20 hours a day,
which would be a great thing for cancer because you'll have downregulated mTOR, downregulated PDKs.
You could get the same benefit by using the fasting mimicky diet.
So you go to the fasting mimicky diet five days a month.
And you stick to the diet that we put you on, you're going to have downregulated IGF one downregulated mTOR downregulated PDK.
You do not want to go on a water fast for more than 24 hours if you have cancer because you'll have, it'll upregulate IGF one.
The only exception to that is if you're doing Kibo, and you're going on a water fast, the day previous to the Kibo, and then the day of Kibo.
It's a lot of information if you have questions, you could post another question on Facebook, rewind this video and listen to that again.
The best way to heal from a surgery, if you have cancer, is to try to don't regulate.
Keep a head on IGF one at MTOR, and you do that through the fasting mimicky diet.
That answers that, that will help.
So if you have more questions on that, feel free to call or to ask on Facebook.
Next question in my situation.
Of course, would you recommend doing another IGF, IVG test in three months.
So the answer is, so everybody's different, right?
So if a person was diagnosed with cancer before, they came to us, which was obviously everybody.
And we do an IVG test, and let's say they were stage two cancer, we do an IVG test, they're below 20.
So they're at, let's say, a 16, and they're feeling great.
We don't know what they were before, but if they were stage two, stage three, stage four, they were for sure above 20 at some point in time.
So now they're below 20.
And that's great.
By what word of caution, that maybe I don't make this well spoken enough, is that do not get complacent with your protocols.
I have seen doing this for 20 years and I've been doing this though with cancer patients.
I've had cancer patients stage four that were given three weeks to live two years later.
They're feeling great.
When one guy he had a back brace on, he couldn't barely walk.
He had a full body, one of those plastic strap braces, all over his back because he had, he had kids are all through his spine, all through his body.
They gave him weeks to live.
This was two and a half years after that, he had no body brace or anything anymore.
I hadn't seen him for about six months.
He comes in my office literally and falls onto it.
I'm not exaggerating.
He's gone to the front desk nearly falling down with this great bang, bang, bang.
And I like, oh my gosh, what's going on?
I ran out to the front.
This is my other office.
What's the matter?
And he was like, collapse.
He had his wife who had driven him there came, had parked the car, came in and said, he's doing really bad.
He's doing bad.
He stopped using the right three months ago.
It stopped taking his stuff four months ago because he was convinced that Dr. Cutters cured him with this cancer.
And first of all, I've never, ever, ever told anybody that they're cured of cancer because I don't even believe that.
And number two, I didn't do anything.
So I don't cure anybody and, you know, that's just the facts.
Do not stop what you're doing.
I don't care.
How good you feel it?
How good your IVG test comes back.
So rule number one, do not stop what you're doing.
Rule number two is when should I do it over the IVG test?
Well, really, the only honest answer is it depends on how deep your pockets are.
So it's for $50 to test.
If, if buddy is not really an issue and you've been blessed, you may want to do a test every month.
But still, even at that, it might be overkill.
If you're doing really well,
and your score was a 16, do you really need to do it every month?
No.
But if you want to make sure that you're going to catch it if it's going the wrong way, it might be good.
So when I say three months, I'm just guessing two.
So there is no protocol here.
So this is a very new test.
We're creating a protocol as we go here.
So is it three months of good window?
It seems reasonable to me.
How are you doing?
How are you feeling?
If there's a turn for the worst in that category, be like, I don't know what's wrong with me.
I just feel like I'm trying to get, I don't know what's wrong with me.
Well, if you can't get in here to get tested again, then maybe we should run another IVG test.
So everybody's a little bit different.
You're going to have to make the call.
I'll give you a range.
One to three months would be a good range for everybody.
I don't care what your score is.
But certainly if your symptoms take a turn for the worst, you should do it before that.
Next question.
My ecologist recommended drinking tea from Graviola leaves to fight cancer.
First of all, I want to know your oncologist name because I have never heard an oncologist recommend anything natural.
That is fantastic.
Do you have knowledge or an opinion of this?
Good question.
I think Graviola is great.
Graviola is or sour sump is in our medicinal mushroom.
Our medical mixed number one.
So we test people of this.
So if you're all I'm not taking that well then you probably don't need Graviola.
So again, this gets back to the should I take curcumin except.
I'm much more in favor of you, taking curcumin, even though it didn't test on you.
Versus taking Graviola.
So understand I put this little thing in here because it says anti cancer fruit 10,000 times more strong than chemotherapy and killing cancer.
and killing cancer cells. I put this in here because I was looking for a picture of
graviola. I found this and this is a warning. Okay, when you start to see these on your Facebook
feeds and stuff, oh, this, this, this fruit or this herb kills cancer at 98% of cases. Okay,
that's a giant red flag for me because those are just lies because if you could put cancer in a
petri dish and then you put graviola in there, it would probably kill it. But if you put cancer
in a petri dish and you just left it for a few days, it would probably die too. So you got to
be careful of these kind of things. That's all I'm saying. Don't, um, don't fall prey to, um,
to, um, things like this. Like, oh my gosh, I better be taking graviola because it's the best thing in
the world. It is a great thing. If you are taking our medicinal mushrooms, you already are taking
graviola. So just so you know that. If you did not test for mushrooms and I don't have you on that
and you're not taking it outside of what I gave you, then you're not taking it. I don't have trouble
you taking it. If you feel like to do that, no, you don't. Um, actually, I got the name of the doctor,
oh, it's from cancer treatment centers of America. So that makes a little bit more sense. There are
much more, um, following their own protocol and he says that the chatted me, wherever gave me this
question that that that doctor is also in favor of medical marijuana. Great. Fantastic. So you got some,
this is more than the beautiful things. I never tell anybody that oncologists are
need awful people that just want to give you drugs. It's just oncologists are typically
locked into a system where they don't really have any other choice. So remember when I got my degree,
my fellowship at an integrative of kids or therapy, um, everybody else was in the medical
fashion there. And I had, you know, when I was, um, asked them, oh, this is great that you could use
this in your practice. The startle lead comment that I got and I was a little naive at the time
was that they said, no, we can't, we can't use any of this at our practice. We're just learning this
for our family. Um, because they literally have their hands tied in what they can recommend
or they will lose their job. So they just, they don't, it's not that they're all just bad people try to
push chemotherapy drugs on you that you might not want. Oh, there is some that quality of that category.
I'm sure it's just they don't have any other choice. And so, um, partly in order to justify their
position and what they do, they just don't learn this stuff. I can't use it anyhow. So yes,
Gabiola is a great thing to help with cancer, but there's a hundred other great things that we
test for to help find cancer. And but every one of those, they, everything that we use, there's
probably some little graphic that's floating around the internet that says something exactly like this
that it kills cancer and 95% of the people, they're just lies. So just don't buy it to these kind of
things either. So have a balance there in everything you do. Another question, can you share your
daughter's recipe for homemade sunscreen? Well, I didn't have time to contact her for homemade
sunscreen. All I did is Google it. So here is a recipe for homemade sunscreen. This slide, it talks
about the SPF features of all the oil, coconut oil, zig oxide. You do not want to use the, um,
the, um, the, uh, data, uh, nano, nano-nized zig oxide, because it's absorbed. And that's what could
be dangerous. That's what's in the, the store bought, um, not the natural ones, but, um, the store bought
sunscreens. Red raspberry seed oil, carrot seed oil, shea butter, um, and how much you use of this,
these things that it's going to give you more of an SPF protection.